okay um so to get this going i'm the
uh product support and development
manager at australia bioseparations
which is formerly prometic by
separations limited
today i'd like to talk to you about
disposable solutions
and in particular about disposable
columns
firstly i'd just like to take a minute
to mention who we are
what we do and how we got here so
australia bioseparations
is the new name of our company since the
beginning of 2020
this year we started as a spin-off from
cambridge university
as infinity chromatography limited back
in 1987.
in 1989 we began manufacturing and
selling our first affinity or
memetic ligand chromatography absorbance
in 1999 we became a subsidiary of
prometic life sciences
and developed our proprietary base
matrix which is pure bead
we continued to develop our products and
then launched
the multi-mode mimetic ligand library or
mmm plates for short
as well as in 2015 launching the evolve
column range which i'll discuss
in a little bit more detail shortly
we continued to expand and in 2017
rebranded and became prometic
bioseparations limited
and increased our manufacturing capacity
significantly
in collaboration with delta precision in
late
2018 we launched our disposable evolve d
column range
the main feature of this talk
australia bioseparations as you just
heard has been established for over 33
years
and provides a range of bioseparation
products
of which which are or have been approved
in 18 fda or emea products or processes
our adsorbents are derived from small
synthetic molecules
and are manufacturing and manufactured
at a range of scales
up to 1 000 liters in a clean room
environment
and are supported with a full regulatory
package
estrella also provide custom development
and manufacturing services
for both absorbance as well as processes
downstream processing
additionally to complement our
absorbance as well
as providing a platform for our
customers we've launched a range of
evolve columns
so why use disposable
personally it's worth defining what we
mean by disposable
many companies are moving towards
disposable solutions
for greater productivity and efficiency
as well as moving towards single use and
flexible facilities
disposables also mitigate the
bottlenecks in downstream process areas
there are a range of disposal items
available for manufacturers
to use from tubing connectors
buffer and product bags and the list
goes on
these items are usually low cost and are
easily replaced
as long as the supplier and the supply
chains well established
columns on the other hand are inherently
more costly
due to the engineering required and also
the
resin contained within therefore
disposable columns are becoming more
prevalent
but are potentially not single use but
more
campaign use the benefits
of disposable columns are plenty
including
operational speed as in they're
essentially plug and play
and negates the need for additional
facility space
in-house expertise and labor time for
column packing
and qualification as well as cleaning
and validation disposable
disposable columns provide operational
flexibility
and rapid change over with reduced line
clearance issues
due to the nature of disposable columns
usually
not required to be larger than about say
30 centimeters
they're more adapted for the increasing
continuous column chromatography market
and also supports alternative
personalized therapies
i.e smaller scale fermentation batches
and column requirements
sprayer wanted to complement its
absorbance with a column
and in collaboration with delta again
supplying the evolve column
the evolve column range is an easy to
use
cost effective and ready to use pilot to
process scale columns
we currently offer seven different sizes
including a 7
10 14 20
25 35 and now 45 centimeter diameter
columns
which all have a non-metallic flow path
the columns conform to the relevant
regulatory requirements
for manufacture and they are rated to
four bar operational
we call the columns the evolve columns
as although we wanted to provide the
customers with a
standard operational column we added a
semi-disposable twist
this is what we call the refresh kit
this kit allows the customer to replace
the full wetted flow path whilst
retaining the column skeleton
this not only reduces waste but also
reduces the cost as the refresh kit
to replace is approximately one-third of
the price of the column
however to further support our customers
you could say that we evolved and
developed a fully disposable
column
tray developed lab scale columns with
our evolv
r range which are standing for research
the evolv r range is a 5 and 50 ml
column
and scales well to our development pilot
or process scale columns
which is the evolve d d referring to
disposable
both the evolve r and d columns have
many similar features
highlighted on this slide as mentioned
the evolver columns are 5 and 50 mil
with a
0.5 and 5 centimeters cross-sectional
area
and a fixed bed height of 10 centimeters
our evolve d range however has a column
diameter
of 7 10 or 20 centimeters
and comes in three different bed heights
of 5
10 or 20 centimeters
this covers a column volume range from
approximately 200 mils
to 6.3 liters
as with the evolve range the evolve d
columns can be used with all common
process solutions
and are rated to 4 bar operational use
disposable evolve columns demonstrate
good scalability
in this example we use etoxiclear
our endotoxin removal absorbent
we loaded a comparable amount of igg
solution
containing endotoxin onto each column
to about 20 mix per ml
of its orbit as
etoxicly works in a negative mode with
the igg product
passing through the column and the
endotoxin is being retained
the flow-through material for all three
columns
formats exhibit high recoveries of igg
and demonstrated greater than four and a
half log clearance of endotoxin
to below 0.1 endotoxin units per meg of
igg
it is worth noting that in this case the
5 ml column demonstrated slightly lower
recoveries
due to a minor discrepancy in
approaching concentration determination
the evolved d columns can can be
provided with a sorry
the evolved e columns can be provided
with a range of our in-house products
like oxyclear which i just described
but it can also be used as a platform
technology for a range of other
absorbents and resins from other
suppliers
the evolve d columns have been ista
tested
on all our column sizes and have
demonstrated mechanical stability
in preservative kept in cold storage for
up to
two years as well as column efficiency
stability
bioburden and endotoxin testing has been
performed to demonstrate that the column
does not present itself with any dead
spaces
and has good clearance the evolved
columns can be provided as either a
non-gmp version
or gmp-ready pre-packed in our iso 7
clean room environment at our isle of
man facility
all the gmp ready columns come provided
with bioburden and endotoxin testing
with certificates analysis and a full
regulatory support file
developed and delivered to you ready to
use
in addition to the current evolve r and
d range
astray are continuing to expand our
product range
for initial scout work australia provide
our ht1 and 5 columns
which are a simple proven design column
of 1 and 5
mil and we're also looking to bridge the
gap
between our evolve r and d columns with
our
new range of 100 and 200 ml columns
the evolve s additionally
we are listening to our customers and
we're planning to increase our evolve d
column range
with a 15 centimeter bed height as well
as larger diameter evolve d columns
now in summary disposable solutions well
the markets are moving towards this
for ease flexibility and resolving the
issues faced with conventional
chromatography our evolve column
a semi-disposable column with a refresh
kit
has been evolved into a pre-packed
validated fully disposable column
evolve d the evolve d comes in a range
of
sizes and bed heights and provides a
cost-effective ready-to-use column
the evolv r and evolve d column range is
ideal suited to
toxic clear as well as our other
adsorbents allowing for excellent
protein recoveries
whilst providing high clearance of
endotoxin
to levels below 0.1 eu per mig as
demonstrated
the evolved d columns have a
non-metallic flow path like
our evolved columns and are constructed
from pharmaceutical grade material
making them suitable for the
biomanufacturing market
evolved columns have been established to
be a platform for pre-packed gmp ready
columns
for a range of in-house and customer
adsorbents and resins
and we are expanding our range with our
smaller scouting columns
of one and five mil our 100 and 200 mil
evolve s and our different evolve d
sizes
thank you for your valuable time and
attention i'll now take any questions
you may have
and of course if you think of any
additional questions after this webinar
or want to learn more about australia by
separations please don't hesitate
to contact us or visit our website at
www.australbiasoperations.com
thank you
that's great buzz thanks very much for
that presentation just to remind
everyone
if you do have any questions you can use
the chat function
which is currently available and we'll
try and get to your questions
we've got a few questions that have come
through in the meantime buzz
first one asks about the pressure flow
characteristics
of our prepack columns have we done any
work in terms of flow pressure curves
and how do they compare to other sorts
of typical process columns
so we've done uh flow curves obviously
on our empty columns
and they're uh they're very good
obviously
we have um for our
smaller seven and ten evolve d columns
are a three mil id port and for our
larger
20 centimeter diameter evolved d columns
has a six mil
id port now for the columns uh
the float characteristics are usually
defined by
uh whatever bottleneck with the smallest
point which is uh these points
we've performed uh pressure drop versus
flow curves on our empty columns
as well as on uh obviously uh
our columns packed with a range of our
our products as well as customer
products and they all are
as expected compared to uh the standard
columns
okay that's great are you touched upon
the expansion of the the range uh are
you able to elaborate on the sizes
especially
the larger sizes that we plan to develop
so yeah with the
evolve d columns uh we uh we have
developed the 7 the 10
and the 20 centimeters uh and we're we
are
looking in our product pipeline we are
looking to uh develop
a 14 centimeter diameter column as well
as potentially a
25 centimeters that's in the planning
phase as well a 21 centimeter diameter
so essentially to match what we're what
we've done with our evolve column range
okay great and i think it's right you
mentioned uh
packing of absorbance from other
companies
um what's the process for this uh and
how long does that process take
so yeah we we have already uh proven
that we can
uh pack a range of it's a platform
technology where we can pack a range of
uh other suppliers absorbance and resins
into our columns
um and we either as mentioned we either
provide
non-gmp uh columns we can provide custom
columns
where we can turn that around in a
matter of weeks uh
to our gmp ready columns now the gmp
ready columns
what we standardly do is we we would uh
set up a packing development plan
where we would uh create a robust
packing method
uh and then supply that over to our
island man facility
uh to to complete the robustness packing
to develop the gmp ready columns we
normally
see uh approximately six to eight weeks
for
our um packing development and then
around six to eight weeks for the um
for the gmp ready now again that is for
uh materials that we have
not ever packed before so obviously we
we've got an ever growing
uh library of uh absorbance so
if we already have packed the materials
it would be standardly about seven weeks
uh delivery for a gmp rating column if
it's a new material we go through that
process of
packing developments and then hand over
tt to our gmp facility
okay that's great and do you have any
experience of non-agaris materials
yes we do we've packed uh we've
obviously
our materials are agarose based we have
packed uh
other customers aggros based materials
as well as um
resin materials so we have packed uh
other companies resins as well and uh
with great success okay perfect
um do you also supply
a regulatory support package for the
columns and and what does that sort of
cover what sort of details are in there
yeah so we have uh a generic regulatory
support file for the evolve d columns
and
as i already mentioned that covers the
fact that we've performed
the bioburden testing we've done
pressure testing mechanical testing
we also provide the range of
suitability of materials we have
documentation for leachables and
extractables from the materials that
have been provided for the manufacture
of the columns so
we provide a whole host of documentation
uh
as well as also uh tse statements so a
whole range of of documentation
uh suitable for the the customer to uh
to give them the confidence that they
can go into manufacturing
okay perfect at the moment that's all
the questions we have
then buzz so again thanks very much for
your time
um and thank everyone for joining as
buzz mentioned if you
want to find out any more information or
you have any questions then please don't
hesitate to contact us
as i mentioned we've recorded this
presentation and we'll be providing a
link for it shortly
other than that thank you all for
joining and stay safe
thanks everyone thank you